a former top prosecutor in Phoenix will
investigate what happened at a long-term
care center where a patient in a
vegetative state gave birth hacienda
health care hired former Maricopa County
prosecutor Rick Rowley to lead an
internal investigation into the facility
Phoenix Police also launched a criminal
investigation into who raped the patient
last year midday of Eid al is outside
the hacienda health care facility in
Phoenix with the latest midday a good
morning good morning Hacienda Health
Care's Board of Directors say that Rick
Romney will have full access to the
facilities operations and procedures
here in Phoenix to help him figure out
exactly how this woman was raped and how
she was impregnated without anybody
knowing
initially Romney told us he didn't want
to take the job but he did it to make
sure this doesn't happen again it will
be my recommendation that as much
information as can come out will come
out former Maricopa County prosecutor
Rick Rowley says his review of Hacienda
health care will include examining the
facilities management practices culture
and security including the usage of
surveillance cameras door locks and
security guards I'll be looking at their
safety audits I'll be looking at
complaints I'll be looking for protocols
Romley says he will try and speak with
haciendas former chief executive bill
Timmons who resigned last week following
reports that a woman who's been in a
vegetative state since she was three
gave birth we had no idea the patient
was pregnant
does he know how long she was or
anything we have no idea we this is a
complete surprise we were not expecting
this during the five minute 9-1-1 call
staff members revived the little baby
boy after giving him chest compressions
the baby's breathing oh the baby
breathing it never should have happened
Timothy Jeffries was a director of
Arizona's lead social services agency
until 2016 he says he asked governor
Doug Ducey to shut down Hacienda after a
2015 audit revealed concerns of
financial fraud including the facility's
annual average cost of care the report
says it totaled three hundred and eighty
six thousand dollars per client in 2012
nearly three times the national average
of a hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars this is a failure of the worst
and gravest kind and it's a failure that
was avoidable but at the very least
seniors at Hacienda
seniors at the attorney general's office
and and the governor and his team should
have protected her it's important to
note that Jeffries was forced to resign
back in 2016 for mismanagement a claim
that he denies now we did speak with the
attorney general's office they tell us
that they did have a case open criminal
case back in 2017 that was closed due to
lack of evidence and also the governor's
office tells us they did act on
Jeffrey's recommendations and concerns
but they are still working to get
financial documents from Hacienda Matea
we thank you